this is a production of Cornell
University
last semester so I'm going to introduce
them
um most of us probably already know
Marvin since he's been our department
chair since 2000
but um you didn't always start out oh
and his research interests include
stable fairy Crop Production but even
though we start out doing Horticulture
um you first got his fastest Bachelors
from Bucknell University
um in biology and then
um his master's from University of South
Carolina also in biology then finally
when he went to Michigan State
University for his PhD he switched
Horticulture
um
those of you who know a little bit
better probably know that he's a man of
many interests and
um when he loves to play his own and
travel and play volleyball is a really
great Supply at his house I think if you
want to dress as an alligator she might
show us a picture later
um and then if you take his leadership
course to find out even more about him
for example that is Myers-Briggs
personality type is intj which means
introverted intuitive thinking and
judging
um and the reason you got interested in
this leadership course is he realized
there was a difference between what
Colonel said it was going to do that it
was going to prepare its graduate
students to be leaders in the kids in
their communities and what it actually
offered graduate students in terms of
learning how to become leaders so he
decided to organize his class and he
called it the big guns so that's where
the pan function
um Pam is a uh the president of the
cosmos Hill Associates and also a senior
human resource consultant and
organizational development here at
Cornell
she got her bachelor's from Harvard
University and then her master's at the
New York State School in industrial and
Labor Relations
um
he's a really experienced Human
Resources consultant
who's worked with a variety of private
and private businesses and institutions
that have range from local businesses
like moose food restaurants
to huge corporations such as Johnson and
Johnson and Nestle chocolate Corporation
and Rubbermaid and then also to Federal
programs such as U.S IRS and the
department of the army so two really
impressive resumes and now I'm going to
I'd like Margaret panties
it's a real pleasure to be here today
and talk to you about leadership the
Quran I want to make the case that I
think we need more opportunities for
leadership development particularly
amongst our graduate students and the
second case is sometimes what we think
is leadership sometimes isn't really it
doesn't really mean
so
I'm going to start off with an uplifting
article it came out this summer the
Republicans are most widely read article
ever send your kids
and turn your kids into zombies There's
a large critique about ivy league
education but the one piece of relevance
I'm going to pull out there is this
particular few serious one idea of a
ball is communicated it was a speaker
supposed leadership Harvard Wisconsin
today
what these institutions mean is
leadership is simply getting to the top
and it doesn't occur to people in charge
of elite colleges and the concept of
leadership
ought to have a higher meeting or really
many
so that's a pretty skating critique of
what we teach at the United school and
if you want more critique you can go
ahead and read the article
but
one of the things I thought we could
start off doing is think about what it
means to be successful now people
sometimes shy away from the term
leadership because I don't want to ever
be a leader most people want to be
successful and most people who end up in
leadership positions were judged to be
successful at some point in their mind
and people have written a lot about what
it takes to be successful
and so what we're going to do is to
spend a few minutes get any groups and I
want you to come up with a list of some
things that you think characterize
successful people and then we'll compare
your list with what people who study
these things
okay let's take a few minutes you can
stop select just get into groups and
just someone described a necklace like
characterizing successful movies
I can see by the level of conversation
that you all have
an abundance of ideas so we want to hear
from you
let's start in the back with the rump
caucus
um enthusiasm organization satisfaction
with life path resilience make the most
of interpersonal relationships
passionate about what you do but not
insanely passionate
able to focus translate share
um humble humility acknowledge one
shortcomings and be okay with that
ability to listen to other perspectives
okay wow quite the list thank you
um this group what would you add to that
we have like three three points so far
was uh able to communicate properly with
your group
that was a leader uh do you want to send
goals
you know where you're going and the last
one we have is to be able to be
open-minded so it was considering
everybody else's position and not just
being you know narrow
okay our gift is um happy with who you
are and what you're doing and a passion
for it being courageous accomplishing
personal goals being able to relate to
people good communication skills
um having a positive influence on people
and others in your group and being able
to recognize the value of what it is
that you're doing creative problem
solving and able to accept and adapt to
change uh persist being persistent while
also understanding your own limitations
and economications and being realistic
about that and knowing your own
strengths and limits
time management willing to be wrong
we have a lot of the same ones but a
couple of things that are were not said
so many times yet for Mastery of a given
skill set vision and poor thought being
able to specific problems and another
thought was success depends on how you
define it
well our group came up with empathy
missionary hard-working inclusive
capable of decisions is enthusiastic
communication skills within the group
can also outside and heifer and I
realized we missed the most important
one which is humor yeah
decisive and then delegating well
do you have anything on your list
um yeah yeah you covered a lot of it we
put a self-evaluation the ability to
give and accept criticism uh and
attention to detail for the on the
Baylor game okay great that was a
wonderful list yeah yeah so you know
people write books on how to be
successful so I try to do is go through
those and bleed out the top
characteristics they say are try to be
successful and I think a lot of people
also have all these in one form or
another on the list of her vision and
vision enthusiasm working hard
no one said management conflict that's
an important point
be accessible so a lot of these others
are communication and so forth
but you know I didn't hear anybody
mention the thing that we spent almost
95 of our time doing
which is having specific knowledge of
skill we spend a lot of our time
teaching people how to do things
having uh
okay so I've missed that so the master
is sort of skill set
the point I want to make though is we
spend most of our time teaching and
working on that piece of it at the and
these kind of I don't really ignore
these others but we don't really
deliberately focus on that and try to
build expertise in some of these other
things but a lot easier innate they kind
of come naturally people but others can
be improved upon in the middle of time
and that's why I think that we need to
offer opportunities for our students to
build those skill sets now part of the
bottom I think we have in our community
is this thing called science
fundamentalism this is the definition
that you know the only thing that's
important is science if you don't do a
science there's nothing else really
matters
and I think sometimes you know feel that
a lot or at least fear that sunlight so
the question when I ask is there a place
that research one University is like
Cornell we're developing skill sets in
addition to Scientific confidence
if so the answer is yes you all listed
all these things that are key to success
can we make room for developing these
skill sets in our students
and do we model those ourselves as
faculty how do we teach those skills
so those are the questions that um
I want to Grapple with today and if you
look across the University
there are lots of opportunities for
leadership programs throughout your
students and you know Pam happy with
this because she's travels in those
circles quite a bit and we listed all
these up here
well what's missing that list
there is no real program directed for
scientists
you know that even the engineers figured
out this is important
so as Maria mentioned the introduction
that was a Genesis for a tribal at least
something at least the chorus providers
to help teach some of these efficient
skills
now the course generally has 20 to 25
students in it how many graduate
students are there in college
on hundreds hundreds hundreds and the
number one reason we hear why people my
students don't take that class because
my major advice would that will only be
spending time outside the lab recently
classes they consider it well not
important and yet all of you just
collectively identified all these trades
that make people successful to make
people good leaders
yeah those are the run in the market
positions don't want our students
doing these other things because they
should be in the lab of working on
design so I think that's a real problem
with our culture here at Cornell
can we claim to develop leaders when we
don't provide our students with
opportunities to develop skills for
Success other than confidence in science
well I don't know if you can but we do
we have lost leadership abilities civic
responsibility and curiosity assessment
of the front page of this house
then there are lots of courses at
Cornell that
uh sort of get out in leadership in one
aspect or another this is a course
inspiring leadership
and the goal of this is to expose you to
the habits practices skills and mindset
common twists during our leaders through
discussions meetings exercises films and
guest videos
it sounds to me like a class where you
go and sit
and typical things happen but I'm not
sure whether it actually engages you in
a significant leadership experience
Hotel offers a program where they expose
you to meaningful leadership
opportunities by interacting with
hospitality leaders so put students in
the room the people that are leaders and
somehow
okay now I'm saying this is that this is
a good thing to do but I'm not sure if
it's really comprehensive in this
approach the vets do you know they have
something too leadership program here
it's an intensive research oriented
initiative
but again I would argue that yeah
there's nothing wrong with that but I'm
not really sure what that really teaches
leadership in the sense that we should
be teaching this because
so I think too often our approach to
leadership training even when we said
we're going to do it is on the plasmosis
put people in the room with leaders and
they'll somehow become leaders and stuff
and often doesn't work out and we also
don't address the day-to-day issues that
must be dealt with quite good leaders
it's fine had a vision and all that but
you know it's the implementation that it
doesn't make or break and oftentimes the
devil's in those details and you can't
just be a big picture person in ignore
the details you've got to kind of work
in both levels
a lot of Business Schools you know
that's kind of a forte if you look at
almost every mission statement a very
business school in the country it's
going to say you know we developed the
leaders for the future and the CEOs and
Business Leaders and so forth and this
is one I just pulled out of Chicago
School business
it's 1898 we produced ideas and leaders
that shape the world of business our
rigorous system and based approach
business education transform our
students into competent effective
respective Business Leaders compared to
face upon this challenge that's a great
mission statement and you know I I hope
they do that another article that came
out this summer was five MBA programs
non-produced leaders and it was a
critique of the Chicago business up 100
programs like that but today we produce
leaders but they really kind of miss a
mark and these are the critiques that
Drew Hansen made of course Magazine
first of all he said that leaders
understand people mbas and then again
oil everything down to numbers
you want to try to lead despite looking
at the numbers and metrics and so forth
like that you're never going to succeed
because behind those numbers and metrics
are people they have Ambitions and
passions and feelings and sensitivities
if you ignore that you know you ignored
your own curl and the Jews has a few
skills compatible with the rest of the
curriculum and they've got lost in that
all the hard analysis of technicals so
that's one critique mix of the
businesses
big three the second one is the leaders
see the big picture the NBA's
unfortunately you learn about business
in the street Parks I know I've never
went to business school I don't know
whether that's right now
about a critique or not but he says it
is that you learn about things in the
position but you don't really step back
and look at how everything's connected
how one thing connects with another
connects to another and they tend to put
things in silence and this but this
isn't
and then the third critique he makes uh
Business Schools leadership is that
strategic plan is essential we don't
have to do it but executing the plan is
what sets good companies apart from that
and schools teach strategic planning
where they fail to teach how to execute
because they do not understand how to
bring people together to work in teams
to get things done
it's one thing the Strategic plan here's
what we're going to do but then how do
you implement that and make it happen do
that you've got to understand people on
how to build teams and how to carry
things out and a lot of times people
that are leadership positions fail to
pay attention to the details and so
it failed the contacts
Harvard Business review of Marcus
Buckingham says those who taught on the
field of leadership development the
model Works something like this we can
be the top performers pick your brains
with the best techniques codify those
techniques into a formula and we have
best practice so once we discover it
turn into formula it's just a matter of
bringing you in line to perform this is
what works you do it you'll be
successful too
but he was honestly it could it be
otherwise your leadership development
instead of being tailored to individuals
the answer is yes
it's feasible to build a system that
delivers perfectly different training
context to different types of leaders
so having said all that sort of
background
what I felt years several years ago was
needed was a course about leadership
skills for emerging scientists build
confidence and people skills it will be
an important component of success after
graduation
also of course it doesn't teach
leadership through osmosis don't put
people in room leaders and hope that it
rubs off by doing and experiencing
the course it recognizes that
individuals have different strengths
and that there are different types of
leadership needed for different types of
situations and understand suspect
academic leadership may look different
than successful leadership and other
sorts of organizations
I mean that's why we probably don't take
you know a four-star in general and
bring them in to run Cornell you know
there's a type of leadership that works
really well
here so there's different sizes
understand that this isn't one size fits
all additional model and I understand it
there's different types of leadership
stuff different types of organizations
so that's what we're about in our course
in LS 5100 our philosophy is we learn by
doing you don't learn by listening you
learn by doing and engaging in
activities that serve you
you know condition your brain to fuel
and experience my life
the course is individualized people are
very different than Maria her
introduction
told you my Myers-Briggs Timberland
index type I'm Poinsett Valley is the
same as pans and you covered five to
this I think that way a lot of you in
the room are probably the same way but
it's important to realize the way you
are and the way you see things because
there's only one percent of the
population that are like us like some of
you one percent and there are other
types of 10 percent of the population
that way so it makes a real difference
whenever we're working with other people
understand why we by the way we are my
other people
that's why I mean by individual lives
and then contextual a lot of the I just
sort of mentioned that leadership in my
contacts whether you
know we didn't military or medium
University or the department or section
is very different depending on what the
context is and the type of relationships
and decision making you have if they do
and it's intensely personal
the
stories and things that are shared to
really be meaningful they don't come out
of the textbook they come from
Individual sharing very personal
experiences with each other and how they
felt how they reacted in those
situations we were taking you know what
they could have done differently what
went well but didn't know what else was
very personal and so a lot of the
conversations have happened in that
class
stay within that classroom the reason
what she learned about me in class I
like Grace
so our course has a syllabus it's 10
weeks long it starts in the winter
semester It Ends by spring break and we
do these 10 different things so I'm
going to show up and talk about what
we're going to talk about the others the
first week we talk about about
leadership is and what doesn't mean to
be a leader so what of the activity that
you engaged in here
we would have time we always kind of
like put a little twist in things what
we might have done is pick the group
leaders ahead of time and told one of
the group leaders I want you to be very
opinionated and obviously what anybody
else says
it used to be that way another person
would be really bushy and not have any
opinion and the third person might say
oh you don't want to say anything the
Mind offend the administration so let's
not say that so while you're engaged in
this exercise these people behaving in a
certain way and you're forming as
opinion about them oh man all right
and then when you talk about and resolve
you can you get the information but you
also think how did you think about how
science and Power in that as a leader
and he said wow how did you feel about
that when the person went to a charge
listen to you and said what it kind of
brings that out so those are the sorts
of things we do in this class
uh we talked already a little bit about
personal style on leadership using the
Myers-Briggs temperament Index this is
originally developed during World War II
when all men went off to war and there
were all these jobs that needed to be
done here in the United States you know
people have to do them were women most
of the women hadn't received any kind of
training they were Housewives and now
there was opportunities to do work and
they were needed to do work by the
country but you didn't just want to pick
somebody up and say oh you're going to
work in the steel mill and you're going
to work in the the library and you're
going to do this and that
so a baseball program doesn't work
they developed this personality
tournament and actually take this test
and it can tell you what career what
sort of types of work really fit your
personality well I don't think
successful hardly successful and it's
still used to this day
more than a thousand PhD uses written on
the BIOS events how many people here
have done Myers Briggs oh okay so
probably about whoever happened
so we do that with the students
and we talk about the whole
education to that we also do something
called strength binders this is a
another
way to understand yourself that was
developed by Gallup and those folks that
identified 34 strains that people have
and with for you you answered a bunch of
questions to support that identifies
your top five strengths so you know what
you're good at you can play your
strength I mean the big part of
leadership is understanding this stuff
that's the first step understand
yourself know where you're strong where
you're weak so you can kind of
compensate for those weaknesses and go
understand so we do that for the first
three weeks and then the last thing we
do on the part about understanding
yourself is how do you present yourself
to the outside world
now we know one of the first things that
happens when you apply for a job
is that the employer potential Reporter
Goes on Facebook to see what kind of
person you are and that is definitely
the case there are people here in the
admissions office that's what they do
you have people who go on Facebook a
prospective students and then judgments
based on that
now one of the things about Facebook if
you hang out with some shooting
characters like I do you don't have any
control over what they post on Facebook
so I'm one if you have the folks looking
about me something I want to give it to
them so they don't like search around I
want to print up something really easy
so they can understand who I am and one
of the things that we do in the class is
we ask the students to develop the
electronic portfolios sort of captures
what they're about so they can send a
link to their electronic portfolio as a
potential employer so they can look at
their portfolio and learn about them
that way instead of like fishing around
with all those dark corners and trying
to find out what's out there so I'm
gonna
show you
careers
so much for what happens
basically they're attacked across the
potty and each of the tabs
says something about you and a lot more
detail in the resume anyway so I've
heard Maria she has a little bit here on
her research project and including some
pictures and
linked to her resume or poster that she
did it's really nice to be able to do
that
class she did some reflexes on
leadership but when it needs to be a
leader did an essay on Rachel Carlson
and what that how that influenced her
personally and so you can put all that
on your electronic portfolio your
teaching and learning experiences
Peace Corps and so forth and a little
bit about her own interests and things
that you might not know about in reality
swim teams you're going to Marathon and
employees are so just those little tabs
that I tell you a whole lot I think
about Maria that you wouldn't have
gotten from a resume
and so we want our students to do that
with that
I I did one for myself
because I think it's great to put up a
page about me a little bit about my
research
pictures and so forth
teaching experiences
some links to other websites
my own reflexes on leadership
transformative experiences
a lot to me and then okay since you said
my special talents and skill sets some
of the work I do in Guatemala I put
there some of the trips I've done I
think down here is my alligator
wrestling
so they're really great there's
electronic portfolios so we have
students do that so then after that
fourth week they you know learn about
themselves and they put that out there
for the world
that from there on
we go into some other things
so
people in this class generally aren't
from all over the world
and they're going to go back out to
organization that are full of them or
touch clients or
parts of the world that are different
than internet so we spend a lot of time
talking about cultural fluency it's part
of the context for you if you do
leadership basically textual and it's
important to understand the Norms of
different cultures before you insert
yourself into the culture you're using
Western norms and fail literally
so that's a lot of the news in the next
experiential work with that people share
stories about things that have been
particularly interesting or jarring in
other cultures even if
this culture and experiencing odd things
here
it's usually very funny and very
interesting and stimulates more
conversation about how it is to work in
a different and diverse workplace than I
ever hear of any form of seminar from
the subject
so we think it's really really broadly
then we really talk about how you think
about
including different opinions different
kinds of culture
different backgrounds different sites
I'm trying to Interior leadership
practice
and spend time doing that
and then we get into simulation we've
built a simulation that makes the
participants actually
become members of an organization with
some roles and goals things they have to
do timetables they have to use
and we let them go or better or worse
things happen people are encouraged to
reflect upon what happened
talk about how they felt about what
happened
what surprised them about the
experiences what might be done
differently again it's a lot of fun but
there's a lot of Applied trying of
things on precise trying things on
precise that people have already learned
from each other and from the things that
we've talked about earlier
and
and trying to make a difference in the
actual simulation
then we talk about how to motivate which
seems like it's an obvious thing I'm
trying to spend a lot of time with
corporate leaders who have assumptions
that are fairly old dated and based on
no science whatsoever
how you actually motivate people
and
the link to Bear all the different
cultures that we're working on Union and
how motivation really differs across
culture but we also talk about what
science really does know
think about how to try it out for size
and
graduate work that you're doing graduate
organizations you might be in an
organizations where you're actually
people are working as a deviation
certain organization or summer job or
ultimately going out
then we talk about conflict which is of
course for those of you who are not only
one of my favorite things to do really
not be in Conflict but because it's an
opportunity really to change things for
the better
will get unhappy they complain
playing it's an opportunity to
understand
that's how we think about leadership
generally when things blow up it's a
time to think about what it is we are
you know missing
we can be better
role plays with that and go through
cases about the
work with you know protocols and things
that actually work and I think a lot of
fun will actually
encouraging people to go out and try
size
not starting conflicts
figuring out some ways to make
situations
work better
and then lastly the evaluation that we
do of the program is actually built by
the students in the program
so how you think about what it is you
should be learning and how you really
get the students to share whether or not
they've learned it
it's a difficult thing that people are
asked at the end of the class to fill
out a sheet
it can often leave things open to
question do they really get to share all
the things they wish they shared about
the a class impact of them or do they
not so this is a full class where we
really spend it on
how do you know if you've become
successful how do you know if the class
would work to do the things
so the students design the questions and
then we worked
what the answering other questions and
analyze the answer
test
classes are three hours long
so it gives us a lot of opportunities
so that's the syllabus
any question on that before we put you
into an exercise
yes if you've kept track of the
graduates and where they have ended up
since you've been teaching it well some
of them are now by Facebook friends
Parish of thought right it
many are with us on LinkedIn Marvin may
have some more formal links I know I
hear from the students many of the
students myself via email as they travel
throughout the world
that they've learned yeah I guess that's
your question do you not have a formal
way of collecting information on what
these students do we're lucky if we can
do that in our own apartment section and
we have students that come from all over
the campus so it's really hard to keep
track of them unless they voluntarily
let us know what you're doing it's
something but I don't really have a way
of comparing that group with six I think
it's made a real difference in their
success but I will say because I've had
people tell me that even though they may
not ever go into a scientific career
they feel what they've learned in this
class is going to help them be a better
person helping with their families I
have them with their friends and all
sorts of relationships they have
throughout their life because this
course essentially is understanding
people how what makes people taken out
the operating so
hopefully it helps to become a better
person in the relationships
yes which departments have contributed
the most participants to this class
where do you think you have the best
buy-in or or where do you think you have
to make more in ruts that's a really
good question I think probably the worst
buying or planned scientists and from
there but it's a hard sell for the
planet science Community I mentioned
earlier you should be working in your
lab we've had really good buying from
food science almost every year we got
food scientists natural resources have
been really good about exciting students
that way and I'm trying to think we've
had students from all over cows actually
and increasingly from engineering
again it's different from the business
school last year
an indication that uh
it's interesting when the scientists are
doing more about managing than the
social business
and we have had students that you know
we Define life sciences in a very broad
sense and here you know anything that
involves people in a sense with a
scientific approach scientists so we
have been getting quite a few students
from the safe development sociology as
well as a one or two from maybe out so
it's really it's one of the things that
makes it really fun is that the students
come from all over and their experiences
that if you want to talk about you know
bad examples that's great yeah
well have you ever seen this happening
there's all that lots of stories if
everyone were from planet Sciences we
wouldn't have that basically but because
of all over the place that's the good
but I would like to see more plant
scientists
it was interesting I participated
focus groups or the strategic planning
process that is the last year and and
one of the things we heard from graduate
students in these groups is that they
are routinely exploring
leadership training where they can find
it and often thing it's a dumbass don't
tell proposition they don't tell their
advisors that they're pursuing it for
fair they'll have a discussion about
maybe the time could be differently
spent and with no malfeasance on the
part of the people who are guiding them
it's just that they have a lot to do in
a short time to do it let's actually
funded so the students were very mindful
of that but craving these
yeah
and there were actually some people
who've been through the class who were
in their
proselytizing for us I didn't have to
say the word it was great
another question
yes okay I just I haven't formulated
this really well but when I think about
my own experiences learning to work with
people and organize with groups and
things like that many of the most where
I've learned the most has been actually
trying to do it so working in community
groups and things like that and so I'm
just wondering how you think that might
be better incorporated into a graduate
education opportunities to do authentic
working groups and reflect on it in
community with other students
this is an interesting question I think
it's it's
students who come to Ithaca have to get
their feet wet and how it is to wear a
winter coat you know what I mean they
have to learn the local culture learn to
kind of opportunities there are not just
to be a graduate student organizations
or clubs but to be involved where they
live and doing other volunteer work or
not doing Project work and some of them
do and some of them don't
I don't know if I have any guides or how
this should work are there any thought
about this it's a good question it's a
really good question and I mean I think
for the same reasons that students feel
they didn't have time to take the class
they also don't have time to get heavily
involved in the community to work or
other than certain activity so I don't
know how we can
I don't know if we can enforce that
change but I think what we can do as
professors is we can model that behavior
and show you can also be an excellent
scientist but also be involved in the
community group or two and do things
outside the classroom and invite
students into that community
between role models is an important to
sort of open the door
sort of related to the earlier question
um as you know there's this thing called
engaged engaged learning at Cornell
primarily I think targeting
undergraduates
he's also engaged for search which would
be appropriate for The Graduate students
but it raises the question for me is
this restricted to grad students or
would it be open for upper level
undergrads but for that matter if
engaged Cornell is going to succeed if
we're going to have students out there
in communities during the summer or
otherwise engaging with real
organizations real communities you see
this big Cornell is going to need a
suite of courses like this that all
students may be required to do before
they go out there yeah so you know our
class has the Supreme 20 and 25 and
that's like ideal
for this sort of this thing and if we
open it up and we want I wouldn't
necessarily want more than that probably
30.
but I also think that we did have one
undergraduate kind of she's not getting
somehow I don't know exactly
she was a good contributor but the life
experience was very different for her
than it was in graduate students like
Maria yep it's been a couple years
overseas and Peace Corps and she just
had a life experience it was quite a bit
more bricks than them so I think that
yeah absolutely courses for undergrads
used to be good but I don't know if you
can mix them in the same classroom and
have the same result and accounts asked
an undergraduate leadership class that's
we're here I believe they have it was so
popular that I think they're now running
two sections
hey Marvin yes this is uh Kristen smart
I was wondering if you guys talk about
diversity and Leadership I know that in
Academia that's one thing that we're
frequently looking for and so I'm
wondering if there's any way to include
that in the leadership experience it's
already in there we talk about it an
awful lot we try to challenge
assumptions that are made about how to
do this work but we try to really talk
fairly openly and honestly about what we
know to be going on some of the pitfalls
of doing this kind of work and how to be
thinking about it in the viruses
different players or anything wouldn't
that be a fair assessment yeah I would
say it's first and foremost on our minds
as we go through all these is
appreciation of diversity and how to
handle diversity how to manage it and
work with it to be organic I think of it
as a productive
here's a person with a perspective a
different skill set it won't that really
help our country
did that answer the question
yeah
Pam I'm in your research what do
employed employers leaders uh point out
as the chief motivators for the
employees with whom they work
hilariously
corporations in particular
tend to rely on things that can be a
more than one size of its own approach
okay
we all have Performance Based today this
is a popular approach to motivation the
assumption is particularly after the
economic downturn that if you have a job
you should
you know and if we're willing to give
you an amk and increase based on some
way that we assess how you've done then
you should be more motivated
enforce but the research literature
really doesn't support that except in a
few very specific very different contain
cases so we sort of take apart the
populists about leadership whether it's
motivated
talk about what kind of research is
there actually
um
especially as we're looking at it
important non-western thinking into how
is that all about working in the U.S
with you know Western based ways of
different businesses so what other
motivators are there that are the most
successful particularly in a
non-corporate setting well I think
you've heard some of it even at the
beginning we asked people to talk about
characteristics the notion of being
passionate about what you do if you're
going to be passionate about what you do
you have to be given some autonomy to do
it
so for some freedom to be able to do the
work that you're tested to do within
certain matters too but to be able to
add something of yourself to that part
second thing is really to be able to be
a lifelong learner you can't just be
doing the same thing day in day out you
have to be able to explore and add to
your skill set if you like your
computer anymore
which those are two really big things
that people need to have and they need
often to be able to be recognized as
being a value member
whatever that is and
what we often see
when I talk to people in the corporate
world
and also not the non-profit world is
this notion that what people really want
is more pay
and then if I give a person you want to
pay a promise to give them more pay
they're going to do more work
I don't think there's anything to back
that up or there's some slim data again
very finite cases but if you say to a
person that you bring meaning you bring
skills you bring competencies we don't
have here's what we trust you to do
here's what you know how can you help us
do it better
people tend to open up so what we focus
on is if you're thinking about
leadership
it's not taking a person as a finite
contribution
plugging them in and sort of lashing
them over the head things like to pay a
nice desk
to make them work hard and we're talking
about optimizing
you want to see people bring more of
themselves to the work because they're
the last of doing because they're
getting something out of it even as
they're added support
I like to say too that that's one thing
I sort of fall coming out for we spent
an ignorant amount of time performance
dialogues and then rating people and
figuring out how much they're going to
make and it's always around two percent
getting parsed out per second and all
the days you know that doesn't motivate
people at all yeah as a research
institution we continue to follow the
the model which so it doesn't work good
we spent a lot of time go ahead
Department chairs it's been a huge
amount of time worrying about that a
little bit of money just doesn't really
give us other things about motivate
people and we don't talk about those
people
well thank you we're out of time really
appreciate your attention
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu